hello everyone welcome to another
episode of uh q a about history of
Science and Technology
um so people have been telling me that
they would like to consume some of this
content in slightly smaller bytes and so
I'm going to try and make my answers to
questions somewhat self-contained so
they can be chopped up and uh provided
in future
um that's will make little difference
but I'm just letting people know that uh
in case it seems weird
um all right let's see we have a whole
bunch of questions that have come in
I was wondering from RBS asking about
the history of automata theory
and uh
uh its applications until today
all right so
you know the word automata is
surprisingly old you know you might
think it was a modern kind of
computeristic word but it's not I think
it was out and about even the 1600s
and I think people as soon as people
kind of had the idea of clockwork they
had the idea of making kind of clockwork
like toys whether it's music boxes or
whether it's more elaborate kinds of
things and sometimes they had it
associated with clocks in fact they
would have you know the cuckoo clock
whether where the little bird comes out
and pecks for a while and then goes back
in or whatever else
those were called automata and they were
various kinds of devices that had
basically gearing based structures
inside and where there were typically
actions that would take place you know
there would be the duck that walks with
its feet and you know nods its head and
opens and closes its beak and those
would happen at different rates and
those would be determined by gearings
and that was sort of a common form of
automata
um and
people I think even Descartes in the
1600s was talking about automata and the
question of for example philosophically
whether we are like automata whether we
are like you know the the duck toy with
its gearing and so on that operates in a
completely deterministic mechanistic way
whether there's something more to for
example human existence than something
mechanistic like that so this this
notion of automata was definitely out
and about and the time of philosophers
in 1600s 1700s things like this
now the uh and there was a famous
actually specifically a duck I think it
was in the 1800s that was famous for
um uh having sort of realistic features
of a duck including it could eat it
could you know it could do all kinds of
things and uh it was merely an automaton
in that sense
and I think
the of course there were also fake
automata like the Mechanical Turk that
was supposedly an automaton for playing
chess but which actually had a a small
person inside the box so to speak it's
sort of interesting that the mechanical
took could have been a thing for decades
because it meant that people's
understanding of what was conceivable
from a kind of clockwork automaton was
really pretty off that people didn't
understand that chess was a level of
thing that was not achievable by an
automaton like that
so
anyway that was kind of the the history
and I think that there are uh by the
time we get to the 20th century
there are kind of more elaborate
derivatives automata like the idea of
robots that came from this uh uh check
uh playwright right which turned into
um uh like these movies like rossums
Universal robots and so it was the 1920s
era movie I think that included kind of
automata like robot creatures humanoid
automata that were up to all kinds of
things that made the movie interesting
I'm sure I don't know whether I've ever
seen this movie I've certainly heard of
it though
um but so that was kind of in the early
part of the 20th century again this idea
of the robotic now as opposed to
automaton uh kind of thing that was
going to be built with a mechanism and
act like an animal person whatever else
that was a thing okay well now we get to
uh
the more formal use of the term
automaton and the idea of finite
automata
so I think the way that that kind of
emerged was this
so electrical machines had been a thing
starting in the late 1800s there were an
increasing amount of sort of electrical
Machinery that had electric motors you
know Faraday for example Hood but once
there was electromagnetic induction you
could start having electric motors those
became practical and you ended up having
these electromechanical switching
systems where you would open and close a
switch and that would allow electric
current to flow or not that would switch
on a motor the motor could actuate
things you could get all kinds of
elaborate stuff that was operating with
a switched electricity and so I think
the only thing that happened was
increasingly complex kind of
electromechanical devices including
things like electromechanical
calculators but electromechanical
elevators electromechanical machines and
factories things like this where sort of
the main idea was to have some kind of
switching Network that
would be uh kind of where this switch
would turn on that switch would turn off
and you would have some essentially
logic implemented in the switching
Network and I think the the early kind
of way of thinking about automata uh in
this in the more formal computational
sense came out of the sort of electrical
engineering of things like that of you
know is the elevator you know does it
have its doors open okay that's one sort
of state of the automaton does it have
its doors closed is it going up is it
doing this is it doing that
um so I think that that was sort of a a
thing that became increasingly kind of a
design methodology and electrical
engineering was something where one was
thinking about states of the financial
automaton so each states of the
switching system
now
I think
in uh let's see there were several lines
of development that will have come
together
so
the notion of a so that that's a very
practical kind of automaton with
electronics and switches and and moving
parts and so on a quite different kind
of thing that is equivalent to an
automaton is something that comes out of
pure mathematics and specifically out of
algebra where you're constructing things
like monoids okay so a little bit of
history there back in
the notion of people had understood
numbers and integers since Antiquity but
the sort of the big advance of the 1400s
and so on was the idea of algebra and
the idea that you could have symbolic
variables X and Y and so on standing for
numbers and that you could do
manipulations merely at The X and Y
level that will be true for all numbers
but still the x's and y's was supposed
to actually stand for numbers
the sort of big idea of the 1830s and
particularly people like Everest galwa
was the idea that you could have things
that weren't where these variables
didn't stand for numbers so for example
one of the Alternatives would be that
the variables stood for operations like
like do a rotation by 30 degrees do a uh
you know do a reflection and that you
could have essentially uh products of
those things you know dual rotation do a
reflection do another rotation Etc that
you could represent those just like you
can represent an algebraic expression x
times y times Z times W or whatever you
could have something where the X always
represented a rotation by 30 degrees the
Y always representation represented in a
reflection something like that and you
could write down sort of a symbolic
expression that represented that series
of operations and then you could have an
algebra of such things which say oh you
know Reflection by this amount if you do
it twice you'll get back the Identity or
if you do a rotation and Then followed
by another rotation you'll get a
different thing and so on so you have
these algebraic expressions but where
the variables involved in the algebraic
expressions are not uh things
representing numbers they're just things
representing other operations or
representing just abstract or just being
abstractly variables ABC and so on so
that was kind of a key idea in what led
to group Theory by the end of the 1800s
there was kind of the notion of
universal algebra which was oh you just
put in these symbols and there's a
multiplication operation and the
multiplication operation is just a sort
of symbolic thing we don't necessarily
say what the multiplication operation
actually does it just has certain
relations that say you know a times B is
the same where times as this generalized
multiplication is the same as the same
as B times a times a or something
um
so
that led to a bunch of questions about a
bunch of sort of ways to construct to
generalize algebra and in the period in
the late last couple of Decades of the
1800s where there was this big push to
kind of formalize and generalize
mathematics
um this was kind of one of the
directions was to think about
mathematics as kind of it's all at some
level universal algebra
and I think that led to a sort of a yet
different
uh version of finite automata because
essentially what happens there is you
are thinking in your automaton you are
saying okay I'll uh so now let's talk a
little bit about the more abstract
version of automata maybe I should say
something about uh what automata turn
into let's see
uh gosh okay so slightly technical point
so
you've got this automaton and
the way that one thinks about it is it's
in a certain State then it makes the
transition to some other state
so for example the elevator has its
doors closed then it has its doors open
then it's in motion then it's not in
motion each one of these things
uh has a transition that goes from a
state like elevator is stationary with
its doors closed elevator is stationed
with its doors open elevator
Etc so you can make a transition for
example from the state elevator is
stationary with stores closed elevator
is stationary stores open you won't get
a transition from elevator as it stores
open and then it starts moving that's a
that's a transition you don't want
um and so what you end up with is this
graph where you have nodes in the graph
representing States and edges in the
graph representing transitions between
states
so uh for example I don't know there are
you can invent tons of these kinds of
finite automata situations where you're
kind of um representing things that can
happen in terms of this kind of graph of
nodes and States now an alternative
representation is to say let's just
represent the transitions by symbols and
that you know one could have one Edge as
an a another one is a b and so on and
then we can write down something which
is like this universal algebra idea
where we're essentially describing that
graph by giving relations associated
with sequences or symbols because that's
a way of saying o a a is the identity
that means if you follow the a edge
twice or something you'll get back to
the identity
um there are by the way it gets very
confusing because
there are for any time when you can
represent a symbol as a transition you
can also represent the nodes the states
with symbols and you can be saying which
of the which sequence of states do you
go through that's another way of
representing what's going on and so on
but any case so another big sort of uh
use case application area of the final
automaton business was in this this area
of thinking about symbol sequences
symbol sequences from universal algebra
defined by certain constraints which
ones could occur which ones could not
occur that was sort of another Branch to
the whole thing
now uh there were several sort of pieces
of unification that happened so one
piece of unification that happened in
the
1930s I think yes was Claude Shannon uh
his master's thesis I think was Master's
thesis maybe it was PhD I'm not sure at
MIT was something that showed the
equivalence between switching circuits
and which are like final automata and
Boolean algebra logic
um and so this was a sort of an
important unification point of these
ideas about switching the networks logic
automata
um
this is actually gets quite technical
now that I think about it
um but
the uh
uh okay so another Branch was a guy
called Stephen cleaney who was one of
the early American uh kind of uh uh
active people in the area of
mathematical logic
and in the 1930s I think invented this
thing that's usually called the cleanest
star operation
so oh boy
um the uh the other branch of this whole
thing are so-called regular languages
and regular Expressions so
once you have this notion of a graph
where you can go we have these
Transitions and you can go from state to
state and so on it's a way of
representing kind of possible languages
where you could say I can have the
letter A I can have any number of letter
A followed by one letter b
followed by any number of letter C for
example and that you can represent in
terms of a graph where you have a loop
that has an A on it and you keep going
around the a loop and then there's one
Edge that goes has the B Edge and that
takes you to another node that then has
a c Loop going uh from that node so
that's one way to represent things is in
terms of that graph the alternative
which one is familiar with from using
computers and so on is you can write
something like a star b c star and that
was a thing that was developed by by
cleaning
um in the context of mathematical logic
um and it was then taken by operating
systems like Unix and the predecessors
of Unix as and the text editors like
Tico and so on as a way to represent
kind of a match this pattern an a any
number of times a b a c any number of
times
and that was sort of another branch of
kind of uh the use of final automata
for things I mean and that again that
case of of what started in algebra
became a thing in mathematical logic
became kind of one of the levels in the
sort of hierarchy of describing
languages the very lowest level became a
thing when early computer languages were
being built for making lexical analyzers
for computer languages like okay you've
got that blob of of characters and it's
supposed to be a number what can be in
that blob of characters oh it's a it's a
some number of digits any number of
digits that could be a number any number
of digits followed by a single decimal
point followed by any number of digits
that can be a number that you can Define
all of those kinds of lexical units in
terms of final photometer and that was
another big use was in in creating
lexical analyzers that could say this is
the blob of stuff that can represent a
variable name there's a blob of stuff
that can represent a number and so on
there's sort of the higher level that
goes beyond this sort of regular
language lexical level and goes to the
level of context-free languages of
saying you've got this thing followed by
this thing followed by this thing where
you have a more tree structured kind of
thing that's the sort of next level up
in the so-called Chomsky hierarchy but
um
the uh uh the that was and that stuff
was coming in the 1950s
um as kind of uh early computer
languages were starting to be developed
and things like that so that was another
branch of the final automaton world
yet another branch
uh
has to do with deterministic versus
non-deterministic final photometer
so one of the issues is you've got this
kind of graph that represents your
finite automaton and then
one of the uses for that graph is to say
does this final automaton representing
this regular language does it accept a
given sequence of symbols in other words
is there a path that you can go through
in that graph that will consume that
sequence of symbols so it might be a a a
b c c c and that will be something that
was consumable by that finite automaton
I described before but if it was for
example a b b c that would not be
consumable by that final automaton so
would you would say that that final
automatons does not accept that sequence
okay so one of the issues then is
is there
when
you are
um
when you're sort of going around the
final optometrin and you're sort of
feeding in some sequence is there a
unique path that you will follow a
unique sort of interpretation as a set
of moves in the final photometer and
that will correspond to a given string
and that's so-called deterministic
finite automaton but it doesn't have to
be that way it can be the case that a
given string has many different
interpretations many different paths
that correspond to it in the in the
finite automaton it can be the case that
at every node so for example a very
simple example of this would be at a
given node let's say that there was an A
in the string you were trying to read
there could be a single edge that goes
out from that node that has an A on it
so you know which way you've got to go
if you read in an a from the string on
the other hand that that node could have
two a edges coming out from it and in
that case uh you um
uh
um
you won't know which Edge you have to go
out on okay why is this relevant well
it's relevant because there's a whole
notion of deterministic versus
non-deterministic computation
there's computation where there's you
specify the input program you specify
the input to the machine let's say it's
a turing machine and there's just one
sequence of states that the machine can
go through based on that that program
and that input
but there's also the idea of
non-deterministic computation where
there can be many possible sequences of
states that the machine can go through
why is this relevant there are problems
that are for example easy to solve
non-deterministically but hard to solve
deterministically famous example this is
factoring numbers if you could just
non-deterministically that is you just
try all the paths you just find a
sequence of integers that you enumerate
all possible sequences of integers then
you can figure out is one of those
sequences the factors of a given number
and that that so but
non-deterministative you say I can try
all the possibilities it's easy to say
I'm going to get the winner somewhere
but if you're forced to say I have to
only get the winner immediately that can
be a very hard problem this is the P
versus NP problem is the question of
whether whether in fact it is true that
there are problems that can be solved
involved non-deterministically easily
but where the deterministic solution is
is necessarily difficult and that's
remains an open problem we can talk
about that separately but so
in the general case of an arbitrary
computation there's this question of
what kind of deterministic turing
machine do that's always following
through state after State versus a
non-deterministic one that can check out
many different paths this is also a
story of of the hope for quantum
computers is that they are something
which can act sort of like a
non-deterministic turing machine and
check out many paths again that's a
there's a there's a great complexity in
the way that you kind of determine what
the answer is and that's a place where I
think some of that tends to fall down
but in any case most of the time when
you have a a deterministic computation
and you have this non-deterministic
complication for Turing machines the
ultimate things you can compute with
deterministic and non-deterministic
Turing machines are the same but the
speed with which you may be able to
compute them may be vastly different it
may be for example exponentially
different
okay that's a slight sort of Side Story
to the question of finite automata
because it turns out that the final
automata was proved in the 1950s that
the deterministic and non-deterministic
cases are equivalent so for any uh you
can always make from an undeterministic
turing machine a long-deterministic fan
of automaton you can make an equivalent
deterministic finite automaton it might
conceivably be an exponentially bigger
but in terms of the speed with which you
can accept things and so on it's the
same unlike for for things like Turing
machines and so that was a result uh uh
person uh two people I know Dennis Scott
and Michael Rabin uh were mid-1950s I
guess had this result about
non-deterministic final automata and
that led to a specific algorithm
which I've implemented several times in
my life uh for actually turning a
non-deterministic turing Furniture
Thomason into a deterministic one okay
well so what
um the
Planet automata as I say are used in the
lexical analyzers of basically
understanding any computer language
that's one of their common uses uh I've
used finite automata quite a bit because
when you have cellular automata
sequences of cells where they get
updated in a series of steps and at each
step you're just changing the color of a
cell based on the colors of its
neighbors in a cellular automaton
um it turns out
that the set of states that you can get
to so let's say you start the cellular
automation off from all possible
sequences of black and white cells then
the question is as you evolve the
cellular automaton maybe it just turns
into all white so what any any initial
configuration of black and white cells
the black just dies out and it's all
white
okay but there are more complicated
cases where it doesn't evolve to some
fixed state but it evolves to some state
that has potential structure in it but
that structure there's less states that
it can evolve to then that you can start
from if you allow yourself to start from
all possible States the set of States
you get to is a smaller set turns out
that's set for a one-dimensional
cellular automaton is the set that will
be accepted by a finite State machine a
finite automaton so that ends up giving
you a bunch of other uses of final
automata and you can do things like you
can assess sort of how complicated is
that set I called it regular language
complexity
um how complicated is that set you can
characterize that by what is the size of
the minimum Finance automaton that will
accept that set
so anyway a little bit on Final
optometer
um I would say that they are kind of oh
yeah another thing I should say about
final automata is that most questions
you can ask about finite automata
there's a finite answer to them
um the for example if you say I've got
two final automata are they equivalent
do they accept the same set of strings
up you can answer that question
the final automata are very decidable
they don't have questions that have sort
of where you can require infinite proofs
to do things as soon as you go above
find an automata as soon as you go to
let's say well context-free languages
are at the next level up on the sort of
Chomsky hierarchy that involve sort of
trees of where you're specifying Clauses
and subclauses and so on then for
example the question of whether two
context-free languages are equivalent is
no longer decidable and for example if
you go instead of talking about the
one-dimensional case of a final
automaton where you say oh I'm just
going to have this string of characters
coming out and I'm going to accept this
uh I'm going to Define with this graph
whether I allow that string or don't
allow that string whether that's a valid
integer or whatever or not
um the one-dimensional case where I've
just got that string of things that's
decidable you can always answer those
questions in with finite amounts of
computational effort as soon as you go
to the two-dimensional case blows that
up completely as soon as you start
saying oh I'm going to have this
two-dimensional thing where I have these
kind of local conditions like I say it's
like a tiling where I say I have these
local conditions where I say I just want
these tiles right around where I am and
so on
um then it is no longer the case that
you can answer these questions finitely
it becomes a a thing where there are all
sorts of undecidable questions and so on
so find an optometer show up as sort of
the the a base case that is um uh
uh that that's very um uh that's very
manageable so to speak they also the
thing I didn't really go into in detail
is the correspondence between final
automata and uh Boolean algebra and
logic that's another whole branch of
things which was Again part of the story
of the Shannon switching theory is
equivalent to Boolean algebra uh thing
from I think the 1930s
okay A bit of a long answer to that
question a bit more technical than I
expected
let's see
it's a question here from Zayden how did
scientists figure out
the source of the cosmic microwave
radiation
well let's see let me try and tell a bit
of that story
so
people have been wandering forever and
ever
where did the universe come from how did
the universe start
and there were all sorts of theories I
mean for example there was uh well in
many kind of cultural Traditions there's
this notion of kind of
eternal return the universe is a cyclic
thing the universe has people didn't
know how old the universe was people
didn't know how old the Earth was
but uh
the the question that people generally
tended to believe that the Universe had
either always been around maybe it was
changing but it would return to where it
had been and so on
the kind of the big kind of
how did the universe work type moment
uh probably came when when Einstein was
figuring out General activity the theory
of gravity in 1915 where the original
kind of equations that he wrote down had
this very awkward feature that they
would imply that the Universe expanded
and so Einstein said but of course the
universe doesn't expand so let me add a
term to the equation the so-called
cosmological term to basically prevent
the universe from expanding it's kind of
like the universe
uh would um
would be
it's kind of like an additional kind of
mass everywhere in the universe that
will kind of pull the universe back from
expanding okay so that sort of seemed
like a good idea at the time in 1915 but
by the 1920s Edwin Hubble had discovered
that the Universe actually was expanding
by looking in a telescope and seeing
that there was a a Doppler shift
um in the in the Spectra of distant
galaxies and so on and and so and and
there was a relationship between the
brightness of something and it's uh um
and how much it was moving away as
measured by its double shift
so so then it became clear okay the
universe was expanding all right so what
did that mean what were the possible
things which would cause the universe to
expand there were really two primary
theories the so-called uh steady state
Theory and the so-called Big Bang Theory
and the Big Bang Theory was originally
named uh as kind of a mocking of that
idea because people were like that's a
crazy idea that the Universe just
started in a in a kind of a a big lump
and then started expanding a much more
plausible idea seemed to be that somehow
new matter was coming into existence in
different places in the universe and
that's why the universe was expanding
and so the uh a number of astronomers in
the 1940s and 50s
um who were big I think uh Tommy gold
Fred Hoyle they were the big people in
the steady state Theory and uh uh George
gamoff was one of the people on the big
bang side of things
and um
uh so people had kind of imagined maybe
there could have been a the universe
could have started really small and and
hot and expanded but but um and there
was some idea that if that happened that
there would be Relic radiation left over
from the time when the universe had been
really hot at the beginning and the
steady state Theory there was no such
Relic radiation because nothing the
universe had always been kind of big it
had never been sort of scrunched down
into a small thing that was very very
hot
so okay
so then
uh
the uh
then the next sort of part of the story
was communication satellites so Sputnik
was launched in 1957 Sputnik was
supposedly launched for international
geophysical year right it was launched
as a way to oh well it's one of its
cover stories was it was launched as a
way to map out the gravitational field
of the Earth by seeing where the orbit
would go and map out you know where
there are sort of when you have uh
similarly mapping for the moon for
example the gravitational uh
feel the Moon shows the moon has a great
big lump on one side the Earth doesn't
um but in any case the the you know that
was I would say more a geopolitical
technological show-off than than really
to do with the international geophysical
year but after 1957 there were
satellites in orbit
um by when was it 1960 I think uh Bell
Labs had already put up I think it was
called Echo one was the first kind of
communication satellite that was this
giant balloon made of mylar where you
would bounce the radio signal off it and
then subsequently there were other
communication satellites that people
were putting up that were um uh that
that had actual radio receivers radio
transmitters and they were actual
repeaters effectively okay so uh then
the next thing was okay we want to make
these radio antennas that are going to
communicate with satellites
and um the uh uh
let's see there's another piece to the
story
which was a chap called jansky called
jansky
in the maybe 1940s
50s perhaps 40s I think who had
discovered that there was radio emission
from intense radio Mission from some
places in space particularly the center
of the Galaxy Sagittarius A if I
remember right
um the uh uh that was the thing where
there was essentially radio noise coming
from space
and that was the beginning of radio
astronomy
um but so that's another piece on the
side okay but people were making radio
transmitters and they particularly
wanted radio transmitters radio
receivers uh that would communicate with
satellites in the microwave band
um not in the
uh not quite in the same Radio band I
think as a radio telescopes were
operating in but so at Bell Labs
1964 or so
um there were these guys Arno penzias
and chap called Wilson I don't know his
first name
um who um uh were
tasked with you know make better radio
transmitters receivers to communicate
with satellites
so they did that and the problem was
they just couldn't get this receiver to
uh you know they thought they had this
very good receiver with very good
characteristics and so on but it always
seemed to have some noise in it and so
question was what was that noise and
they realized the noise was coming from
all over space
and there have been previously the
regular astronomy stuff there was noise
coming from a particular direction which
was the center of the Galaxy
um but most you know there were other
places where it was kind of much quieter
in the radio spectrum but what these
guys found was that actually there was a
a small amount of sort of residual noise
at an effective temperature of around
2.7 kelvins that was coming from all
directions what was that it actually
didn't take very long for people to say
that's probably something associated
with the early Universe oh maybe the Big
Bang Theory of the early universe is
right and in the 1960s there was kind of
a duking out of these these two theories
and I think what really kind of probably
tipped things over in addition to the
cosmic microwave background and I don't
think there was a lot of uh I don't
think there was a huge amount of
controversy about what the cosmic
microwave background was
um I mean people might have imagined it
was just random missions in the galaxy
and things but I think it was pretty
clear by the time it's in all directions
that that can't be a viable thing but I
think what really uh sort of clinched
things was when it started to become
clear that you could actually understand
how chemical elements were produced how
helium was produced in the early
universe and that you could predict
things like the fact that in the
universe there's a quarter of much as
much helium as there is hydrogen and you
could actually do a computation that
would deduce that that was that was one
of the easier ones that deuterium is
actually a rather hard computation and
that was much more sensitive and I don't
think it was until the 80s 70s 80s that
that got well worked out but it became
it was sort of a thing where people
understood oh in the first second of the
existence of the universe we can use
nuclear physics to start working out
these nuclear
um things um and uh personal woolly
Fowler who I knew
um who was much involved in um uh in
that uh working out of the sort of early
nuclear synthesis and so on
um and it was kind of a big exercise in
nuclear physics and I think think that
that helped kind of uh convince people
about this
so
um
that's that's I believe the story of um
Cosmic microwave background as I say
that was a case where the theory came
before the the observation and then when
the observation occurred it was uh kind
of like oh it fits that theory and not
that other Theory
uh subsequently there were other things
that were observed like the um uh the
fact that
the uh that there's a sort of an
interesting thing that that the Earth is
moving at about a thousandth of the
speed of light relative to the cosmic
microwave background so you thought it
was the same in all directions it's
actually not it is defined by the center
of mass of the universe what the rest
frame of the cosmic microwave background
is and it's kind of weird that we now
observe that we're moving relative to
the cosmic microwave background because
one of the big things that people had
said you know in 1900
um that have led to relativity theory
for example was this idea there is no
preferred reference frame in the
universe it had been the case people
have thought that when it came to the
transmission of light that light was
transmitted through space in the same
kind of way that sound was transmitted
through the air that sound as
compression waves in the air and it
requires there to be air there to
transmit sound and so there was this
idea of The luminiferous Ether the light
carrying ether that will be the
analogous thing for light an interest
interestingly enough even when the
equations are left from magnetism were
written down by James Clark Maxwell in
the
1870s 1860s and 1870s
um he absolutely believed in the Lumina
first ether
um he and and he wrote down his
equations he thought his equations were
describing the Dynamics of the
luminiferacita
turns out the equations were right the
Lumina first ether was not right and
what was done in 1900 Michelson and
Morley did this experiment looking as
the earth goes around its orbit is there
an ether drift is the is the speed at
which light goes
um affected by the um uh by which way
the Earth is going where the Earth is in
its orbit relative to The luminiferous
Ether assuming the luminiferous ether is
at rest
well so what they discovered is oh
there's there is no ether drift and so
that's what led to this kind of the the
speed of light is the same in all
reference frames thing which is what
Reds relativity unfortunately you go
another
um you know 80 years later or something
and people discover that the cosmic
microwave background is actually not
isotropic weak there is a preferred
reference frame it's the rest frame of
the universe it's the Central Mass of
the universe and we are moving relative
to it so the fact that the the Michael
Somali experiment was done and the way
it was done with the Precision it was
done at
um was something that led to the idea of
uh kind of uh relativity but in fact if
it had been done in a different way it
would have led to a different conclusion
oh actually there is a preferred ref
frame relativity is still true but the
justification the kind of philosophical
justification for it isn't quite the
same it is interesting the the times
when there are theories that get
developed where the framework the sort
of understanding of the world is
completely wrong but the theory is still
correct one that I've been looking at
recently is the theory of thermodynamics
where uh Sadi Kano was operating in the
1820s on a completely wrong theory of
what heat is he thought heat was a
substance a fluid that kind of suffused
different materials not that heat is the
result of molecules bouncing around and
he developed these ideas about Carno
efficiency and things like this on the
basis of this completely wrong theory of
heat
um and in the 1850s people then sort of
fixed the idea of the theory of heat but
it turns out what he what Kano had
deduced in the 1820s was still perfectly
correct even with its different
interpretation of how heat works so it's
sort of interesting when that happens
and that's something that happened in
the case of the cosmic microwave
background
um anyway that's that uh
um
what's that story
boy okay here's a question uh much more
techy question
uh questions from Aaron it's asking why
didn't containers become more popular
until Docker around 2013. seems like
they would have been useful very long
before that what did people do instead
you know one of the things that's always
shocking about the computer industry is
that every quote's new idea has been
seen before in some other form
so I have to say
when you know you've got a big blob of
software and you want to take that Big
Blob of software and have it run on
another computer how do you do it
well
back in the day
you would do it by putting that software
on floppy disks taking the floppy disks
to another computer reading the floppy
disks into that other computer
now obviously it didn't you know then
when computer networking became common
you could just copy the file from one
computer to another except whoops most
pieces of software weren't just one file
I mean even Mathematica now of language
I forget when it was that it it crossed
the point of having 10 000 files
and it was in the very early days most
programs were just a single binary but
then people realized and whatever data
that binary needed if it needed a
dictionary oh it was just some data that
was part of the binary but then people
realized it was much more convenient if
you if you factor things out and you
have up there's the binary and you have
various resource files that are
separated from the binary whether it's
you know the setup of the menus whether
it's the artwork for the startup screen
those things don't have to be in the
binary back in the earliest days those
things were always sort of in the binary
as one Big Blob of file but so I would
say by uh hmm
actually probably wasn't well let's see
when did all that stuff come in the um
I would say in Unix in the late 70s
started to be a place where I know
something like the Unix spell check
function would use a a file in the you
know user dict directory or some such
other thing that was a separate file
that wasn't just burnt into the binary
it was something that had been factored
out so I think that that type of idea of
sort of factoring out resources is
something that became pretty commonplace
well certainly by the early 80s
um and uh so that meant that when you
said I'm going to send you the program
it was more complicated because you had
to send not just the single file that
was the executable thing that the
operating system would start running but
all of the dependencies that that were
in there the other thing that happened
was the idea of libraries so back
certainly by 1980 yeah and even in the
late 70s it was possible to have a
running program an executable and then
Link in other executables while that
executable is running so it's like the
computer is running it's got its program
counter it's like oh I'm I'm um I'm I'm
executing this piece of code here oh the
next piece of code I execute oh that was
came in from this other file here but
it's now read into the memory of the
computer and that's what I'm going to
execute next so this idea that you could
Link in external libraries began to be a
thing even by the late 70s it began to
be a thing even in early Unix systems it
was a little bit scary and you could
crash the machine and all kinds of other
things still can in some cases
um but that was a thing that sort of
gradually Advanced the notion of
libraries and then Dynamic libraries and
so on Dynamic libraries weren't really a
thing until sometime in the 90s which
was again a place where instead of just
saying there's this one binary there's
this one executable here it is go run it
you would be like well is this one
executable but it's got a call Dynamic
libraries which come from files and
they'll have to be read in and so on and
so on and so on but anyway way so the
the basic point is by probably the late
80s it was really commonplace to have a
software distribution that wasn't just
oh here's this one file but a big
collection of things you know I'm
thinking my first big Software System
SNP was also a very that was from 1979
um that also had lots and lots of files
on it so I it was um uh and the question
was sort of how would you how would you
install that object
and on Unix for example or on vax VMS or
one of the other operating systems that
was sort of a a
modern-ish
sort of large computer operating system
essentially what you would do is you
would like send the the program on a
tape and then somebody would read in the
tape but they usually use the Unix
utility tar for example or the analogous
thing on on other operating systems and
it would take what was on the tape and
uh then it would unpack it into a
collection of files those files would
sit on your computer system then you'd
have an executable you run that that
executable
on personal computers it wasn't as easy
as that there weren't things like tar
utilities that would unpack files it was
all a little bit more complicated and in
addition when operating systems that had
guise started coming in there were all
kinds of registrations that you had to
put into those operating systems you had
to say oh when you have files which have
a such and such ending I want them to be
opened by this program automatically oh
when I uh you know when I have this
thing I want it to insert itself in the
menu system in this way so it became the
case that it wasn't just a question of
oh put the files on the on the file
system it was more like knit yourself
into the operating system
so that led to the whole world of
installers
and so for example when we first built
Mathematica 1988
um it had installers and actually we
built those installers and we built uh
installers for all the different
operating systems that existed at that
time and it was a whole bizarre
technology of installers and then there
started to be companies that that sprung
up and it was like the first time I
heard of a company whose sole business
was making installers I was like oh my
gosh what is the world coming to uh you
know this seems like a crazy thing but
that got more and more and more
complicated as programs started to have
thousands and thousands of files and
there started to be all this kind of
registration stuff that you had to do
and all this kind of thing
and so that led to first of all uh you
know the sort of more and more complex
installer mechanisms and then it's like
well how do we actually package all this
stuff up and just stick it on a computer
and have it run and it's even much more
complicated when you are dealing with
something like a a thing that's going to
be a cloud system for example and you're
you're doing something where you're
setting up a server that's got all kinds
of tentacles it's got to say you know
how does it connect to the internet
what's its domain name how does it do
you know how does it deal with user
authentication how does it do this or
that thing and there's sort of the ball
of wax gets bigger and bigger and more
and more complicated and so that was
it's sort of uh the the fact that that
got so complicated is what led to the
desire to have some kind of standardized
technology like containers that would
allow you to take this sort of
complicated octopus with all these
tentacles flapping around that were
connecting to all these different parts
of the operating system and so on and
package it all up now you know at
different times different things became
containerizable in different ways I mean
still databases are not heavily
containerizable uh and that that's
usually a thing that sort of hangs off
to the side
um and uh it's a uh now in terms of you
know the details of why Docker took off
I think there was a certain sort of
coolness factor to the whole thing and
you know it's it's a it's a typical
Silicon Valley type story and um uh I
don't know the full details of that one
from the inside so to speak
um I just know it as a sort of consumer
of those things I think there were
several technologies that were kind of
vying at the beginning and then there
were sort of free ones and non-free ones
and different business models and so on
um and I think it also was a thing that
as Amazon AWS and other cloud services
cloud service providers sort of came
online it was convenient to have this
idea that you would have sort of a a
thing that was packaged up that you
could run on those cloud services but
then of course in the usual dynamics of
of competition in the in the computer
industry then somebody said oh no no
let's have an open version that has um
that's more uh uh you know that has a
standard uh and usually that's a reason
that's because some Underdog basically
is saying uh you know somebody some
there's some
company that has kind of a you know that
sort of owns this Market let's make a
sort of an open thing that um uh will um
uh will kind of allow us to get into
that market without having to say oh
we're making another competing thing but
we've got the open one that is going to
sort of uh be transportable to everybody
and I think there was a a certain
Dynamic of that that happened in the
world of containerization
um
so that a few comments about containers
um oh yeah actually there's a comment
from j3 reminding me of something uh
yeah this is a
um
right good point okay j3 is reminding me
about virtualization yeah I should talk
about virtualization
that's another interesting can of worms
so
you know the whole idea of computers
that can run software is you have one
universal computer and you feed in
different programs and then the computer
can do different things
that was the idea that eventually
launched the whole computer industry
that idea came out of mathematical logic
came out of the idea of Turing machines
from the 1930s and so on although the
route by which that theoretical idea
sort of connected with the
practicalities of making electronic uh
calculating machines that would be
Universal in the sense that you could
feed them any calculation to do that was
a slightly circuitous route that brought
those things together but by the 1940s
late 1940s early 1950s that was kind of
a thing the universal computer was a
thing
and so then in principle given any
computer you can run any you can make it
do any computational operation but in
practice different computers have
different built-in instructions so the
actual code you need to run on one
computer is different from the code you
need to run on another computer and so
that meant that for a long time
the um uh there were uh you know you you
would have oh I've got the software oh
it exists for a PC oh it's completely
different software that exists on a Mac
oh it's completely different software
that exists on a lens machine for
example and for example when we were
first bringing out um a woven language
Mathematica in 1988 there was a giant
zoo of machines that existed at that
time there was a lot of uh kind of um
the personal computers were like the IBM
PC and then the Mac that was kind of a
big part of that space level company was
like Atari and commodore and so on which
also were in the personal computer space
and then there was a big collection of
companies in the workstation computer
space San Apollo HP and so on and then
there was another collection of
companies in the kind of supercomputer
Etc companies like convex and um Ardent
and Stella and and so on a lot of
different companies every one of those
computers had an incompatible operating
incompatible instruction set so every
one of those computers needed a
different binary to be created so like
in the case of of mathematical language
the original uh core code of the system
was written in an extension of C that we
developed that was we developed because
it was at a time before C plus plus had
native compilers and so on so we
developed our own kind of
object-oriented extension of c
um and uh then progressively over time
more and more of open languages written
in the language itself
um so it matters much less what the base
sort of core language is but back in
those days it was like it was basically
a giant lump of C code on millions of
lines of C code and we had to Port from
one computer to another and that was
always a big adventure you know how did
you port from one computer to another I
think probably the most spectacular
porting story was what was it a great A2
I think there's a supercomputer
um and uh you know we finally get the
thing up and running there's a big you
know a lot of a lot of effort to get it
there and we type in the first sort of
computation two plus two and in I kid
you not it gives back the answer five
and it's like how could that possibly
happen and the answer is because on that
machine it was so oriented towards
numerical computation that it's stored
every number as a floating Point number
basically floating Point numbers were
really it's fundamental way of dealing
with numbers and so integers were kind
of a a sort of a hack relative at least
the integers we wanted to deal with were
kind of a hack relative to that and this
was somehow some some weird interaction
between the the representation of
numbers and the fact that this was an
integer which led to two plus two equals
five but it's kind of a a um
um uh sort of a strange thing there but
anyways back in those days
there was a um uh you know
probably 50 different binaries that we
had to support
um on all those different machines with
all kinds of separate testing on every
kind of machine
okay so then
one of the things that became sort of an
idea was well let's have a
virtualization layer where you can say
well we're actually running a such and
such machine but we will virtualize
another machine and you know a universal
computer says you can always do that
that's kind of the proof the universal
computer can work is oh that Universal
computer can compute the same things as
that other Universal computer because
the first Universal computer can just
run a program that emulates the second
Universal computer and so that was a
theoretical proof known since the time
of Alan Turing in 1936
um that that was possible but as a
practical matter it's like you can't be
serious you're not going to be able to
actually emulate I mean remember people
talking about this in the in the mid-80s
um you know would you be able to emulate
one kind of uh computer on another kind
of computer and then people slowly
started saying well we can emulate the
instruction set but the instruction sets
were quite complicated and then it was
like well okay we can emulate the
instruction set but what about the
operating system what about the system
calls oh that's a whole nother can of
worms and so on and so but there were
there was sort of an increasing interest
in virtualization and an increasing
interest in basically being able to take
a single piece of hardware and
essentially run multiple virtual
environments
um on that piece of hardware and I'm
trying to remember
what when I first saw that really
working
um
even when we built
let me think
that was the thing that was super useful
as the cloud services like AWS came
online and certainly when we built wolf
malpha and launched it in 2009
uh
the
pure virtualization technology was okay
virtualization of databases was not a
thing and I'm trying to remember all the
details but that was certainly a time
when the the you know virtualization was
was something that had happened and you
know the point about having a virtual
machine is that then you know you've got
sort of your whole machine and it's all
encapsulated and if you're worrying
about computer security oh it's just the
um
um uh you know it's it's it's all
there's an enclosed kind of machine
within a machine
um and um
I'm trying to remember because I I you
know various times I've been interested
in what's the overhead associated with
virtualizing like that I mean and and
the the common case of virtualizing
which wasn't obvious at the beginning
why it will be useful is virtualizing a
machine of one type on a machine of the
same type as opposed to virtualizing you
know having a uh you know Linux running
on your on your Windows machine or some
such other thing it's a different kind
of you know it's same idea and and then
their operating systems like the Mac
operating system which has never been uh
is is not set up to be virtualized
um
and uh but yes I think that was um I'm
now trying to remember because I
certainly lived through a bunch of this
history of um uh of working out you know
how much what is the virtualization
overhead do we really want to run
virtual machines is that really a
convenient thing to do oh the other
thing I should explain is one of the
advantages of virtual machines is that
you can kind of uh you know at a
moment's notice you can kind of bring up
a new virtual machine you've got one
piece of hardware and it's like oh I
need to be running uh you know 20 web
servers on this piece of Hardware oh
yeah okay great now I need to be able to
run 22 of them I just start up two more
virtual machines and you have a kind of
a a seed version of the virtual machine
and you just instantiate that version of
the virtual machine and it starts
running again of course it's a it's a
complicated story I mean this is a
there's again a story that that comes
from things like forking in the
operating system so one of the things
which when I first you know encountered
Unix back in 178
um I was like what on Earth is this Fork
operation why would I want to take a
running program and make a copy of the
running and basically make it so that I
can have another version of that running
program
um that sort of starts from exactly the
same place as the first program but then
you know progressively separates off why
would I ever want that and it took me a
little while to understand kind of what
was the the Great Value in having that
possibility as a way to set up
processors in operating system and so on
and it's sort of the the big
generalization of that idea is this kind
of well let's set up a whole virtual
machine and let's take this virtual
machine image and let's just instantiate
hydrate this sort of freeze-dried
virtual machine
um and and let it run and I guess that
the um I'm trying to remember that the
whole entanglement of that with um uh I
mean I think the the docker story is
more of an installer type story than it
is a story of um uh
um but but I think these things are all
very entangled because you know by the
time you have a virtual machine you've
got to have sort of a version of what's
in the virtual machine and you've got to
have um and then you've got to have you
know where do all the pieces of the
virtual machine connect to and so on
um so uh
uh anyway that's a few thoughts on that
but um uh oh yeah there's a comment from
j3 here about mirroring machines yeah
that's another
oh boy yeah the camp the computer
technology is complicated I mean that's
another whole issue is oh you know I
want to set up a hundred machines for
people around my company or whatever
um you know and I want them all to be
the same how do I how do I make 100
copies and there were specific pieces of
software that did that
um and uh you know sometimes that gets
very complicated because there are
application programs that run on those
machines that are locked to a particular
machine and so on there's a whole other
history that we could tell about the
history of of copy protection I think
somebody asked about that another time
um which again is is one of the features
of all of this containerization and oh
well when you've when you bring up the
container and it has software that cares
about uh the fact that you can't clone
it
um you know how does that uh sort of how
does that re uh reactivation of the
software work and so on
um
all right I think I'm running out of
time and I have to go to my day job here
uh
let me see if there's anything I can
just address quickly here
um
you guys definitely give me my memory a
run for its money I think that um uh I I
have absolutely never thought about the
history of containers and virtualization
and so on
um and to to kind of uh un unpack that
is a little challenging
um I I will say that that um uh I do
remember back and this must have been
the early 90s
uh people who were making friends of
mine who were making kind of
microprocessor Innovation one of the
things that they were hoping for was
that they would sort of have an
instruction set and a microprocessors
that could sort of routinely emulate all
other microprocessors that became less
important as Intel for example started
dominating and the x86 architecture
started sort of dominating the world and
and now it's again more important as arm
architectures are sort of out and about
and they have to emulate x86s and it's
it's all gotten more complicated again
and somehow the whole process of you
know oh it got simpler and then it got
more complicated again it all kind of
repeats and just like we were you know
for a while it was like oh uh you know
you just take the C program and it will
run on any computer well yeah no not
really now it's like oh you've got this
website it'll run on any browser well
not really
um and so you know a lot of these things
that were like you know everything kind
of standardize this down to something
and then it then it radiates out again
and it gets complicated again
um
oh yes William is remembering that apple
had a Motorola to power PC emulator for
their powerpc Max yeah I think um we
were part of the original demo of um uh
that apple had of look you can really
make a port of raw software from um from
one computer to another and that was
sort of a a big dramatic moment I think
uh Teo Gray from our company
um was the sort of on-stage Personality
with Steve Jobs sort of demoing Yes Yes
We Really managed to make this port and
it really was made in a couple of days
um because apple with its its secrecy
and so on was like uh you know the the
people who were actually working on it
were like come to the secret room in in
Cupertino or ever to to prep this right
before the the announcement of the whole
thing
um so it really was was done in that
period of time I think the thing that
always surprised me with these emulators
was
you know is the emulator good enough
let me give you an example of where you
know the the I roll my eyes a bit
because you know the history of the
computer industry comes again and again
and again around and around and around
webassembly
is a is yet another story of you know
emulating emulators and so on I mean
that's a story of can you write in
JavaScript something which will run uh
you know random C code for example can
you take compiled code and run it uh you
know in this crazy Tower where there's
sort of JavaScript interpreter in the
browser that is really running assembly
code and now maybe you can cheat and run
the assembly code directly in the
browser but you don't want to do that
because of computer security concerns in
the browser and so on and so I remember
maybe 10 years ago now a little bit more
we had to make a decision building out
our cloud system we had built for 20
years we built the user interface for
our whole notebook interface system that
was very lovely and is very lovely and
it's very smooth and and so on running
directly on operating systems on and
gui's on computers and then the question
was okay we're going to get this stuff
to all run and web browsers in the cloud
how are we going to do that well people
said look there's this webassembly thing
and it's emulating any you know you can
just take a binary and run it in
webassembly and it's like uh well let's
see whether that really works and of
course there were tentacles hanging out
so for example I don't remember fonts
for example fonts are often very deeply
deeply connected to operating systems
that was a tentacle that was hanging out
and it's still not the case that we
could take a bunch of a binary that
represents uh some of our sophisticated
notebook user interface technology and
just put in a webassembly and have it
run webassembly has other uses but
that's not something even a decade later
that's really going to work and this is
always a challenge in in sort of the
computer industry and there's a reason
why worth knowing some history it's like
what's going to work what's not going to
work I'm sort of always reminded of of a
very early thing in the workstation
computer space
of the sort of two bets that were taken
by different companies by by Sun and by
Apollo so
everybody knew that on these workstation
computers there was going to be an
operating system and there was going to
be a window system and the question was
which was underneath was it the
operating system underneath like a Unix
operating system or something on top of
which was built a Windows system or was
it the Windows system underneath on top
of which was an operating system that
managed files and processes and so on
and Sun bet on you know operating system
underneath Windows system on top there
was a certain amount of cruddiness to do
with some of the way that that got
implemented but that was the thing they
did Apollo betted on it being on the
other way round and the problem was that
turns out the other way around wasn't a
good idea because the Windows system was
just a much more complicated piece of
software than the operating system and
much less well developed and so the
operating system was was you know it
could have bugs and it could cause the
computer to crash but it had been pretty
well shaken out by the time that it was
being used on this the Unix was being
used on this on this computer and so it
was a much more stable thing to say
operating system underneath
um you know Windows system which would
be much flakier and would crash much
more often but if the Windows system
crashed well you'd be thrown out into
the operating system and at least all
was not lost but if you had the
operating system on top the Windows
system underneath the Windows system you
know goes crazy and crashes and boom
your computer has crashed so what's sort
of interesting which one of those was a
bit worth taking and I think you know
one might have been able to work out
from the history of the computer
industry which will be the right bet now
you know these histories work out in
complicated ways so for example another
bet that we've lived a bunch of times is
special purpose versus general purpose
Hardware you know back in 1988 and so on
when we first released Mathematica and
so on people were always coming to us
and saying oh we have this computer with
a very long instruction word we have
this computer that does special kinds of
arithmetic we have this computer that
has this special array Hardware et
cetera et cetera et cetera won't you
support that stuff and we typically say
you know if your payus will support it
and um or sometimes we'd say even if you
pay us we won't support it
um because because what was happening
was these things like the floating Point
unit used to be a separate processor and
you could buy a Mac with a floating
Point Unit or without a floating Point
Unit it was a separate thing
um back in in 1988 and so on and then
the question was would one sort of build
things that were sort of specialized to
the particular kind of hardware for one
computer or not or would it be the case
that in a few years that was all a waste
of time because in a few years that
special purpose Hardware would have
migrated to be part of the general
microprocessor and um uh and then
uh and and supported by uh language
compilers and all that kind of thing so
that it was a total waste of time to
have independently supported that uh uh
that piece of special purpose hardware
and so this repeated itself I don't know
10 times of the special purpose Hardware
people were like look it's amazing it's
special it's uh you know it's going to
make something
um uh go even faster and so on but uh
but then it would get you know submerged
into the general purpose hardware and I
have to say one place so that was the
General historical Trend one place where
that didn't happen was with gpus where I
thought that was going to happen and
didn't happen and it still hasn't
happened it's an interesting thing when
people make sort of special purpose
hardware for neural networks is that
something where it's fundamentally going
to be another piece of Hardware is it
going to be part of the microprocessor
and it's going to be something that's
supported in the generic languages is it
going to be separate kind of uh separate
system calls separate separate language
constructs and so on or not these are
things that sort of the lessons of
History tell one some things about what
one should expect there
um but sometimes the lessons of history
history doesn't always quite repeat
itself and but it's sort of been an
interesting thing that um the whole
question of will the emulator actually
work
is like you know back in the early 90s
people were talking about this and it's
like it's not going to actually work you
know people would try and emulate this
with that and it's like uh no it's just
not realistic
um and I think the um I don't know why
emulators started working at some point
I think it was partly perhaps that some
aspects of operating systems people
agreed to license features of that
software or the or layers that allowed
system calls to work properly I'm not
sure if that was the thing because
otherwise you have to emulate the system
calls as well as emulating the raw
hardware and you have to emulate kind of
all the ways in which things interact
with like device drivers and so on which
gets you deep into the sort of Hardware
of the computer
um Beyond just saying oh we we get these
uh standard you know instructions that
you could get by compiling a c program
to run
all right I better wrap up there thank
you very much for for joining me and um
uh I see there are all sorts of
interesting questions here that I did
not get to and I look forward to getting
to them another time
thanks and uh bye for now